[Musique]
voici mes seins
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer ils
tiennent beaucoup de place dans ma vie
[Musique]
vous pensez peut-être que la vie est
facile pour une femme aussi bien pourvue
par la nature
vous voulez bien retirer votre
soutien-gorge
après les avoir portés et supporter
toutes ces années j'ai décidé de me
faire opérer
je vous montre ce que je vais enlever
je vais fixer les tissus ici contre la
paroi de la cage thoracique pour que
vous retrouviez un joli décolleté je
vous le montre des deux côtés ils sont
vraiment lourds
je peux imaginer la charge que vous
devez porter en permanence
un kilo et demi plus un kilo et demi
égal 3 kg
c'est trop mon corps ne les supporte
plus
[Musique]
mais ma tête n'est pas encore tout à
fait prête après l'opération vos seins
seront ronds comme des demi-lune
au bout de six semaines il s'affaiont un
peu avec la pesanteur et prendront une
jolie forme naturelle
d'après mon expérience les femmes se
sentent bien plus féminines après car
elle retrouve une partie de leur
personnalité souvent elles sont
entourées de gens qui font une fixation
sur les grosses poitrines vous ne serez
peut-être plus autant le point de mire
vous deviendrez peut-être invisible
d'une certaine manière mais ça peut vous
apparaître aussi comme un avantage
invisible simplement parce que je ne
serai plus la femme à forte poitrine
la pomme c'est trop petit c'est trop
petit de toute façon on oublie oui
ce n'est pas pour vous
et les oranges oui ça correspond à peu
près à un bonnet B
oui mais ça suffit pas c'est trop petit
pour vous ce que vous avez actuellement
c'est à peu près ça oh mon dieu c'est
super lourd
[Musique]
voilà je crois que j'ai trouvé la
solution
comme ça je me fondrais dans le paysage
ou pas
c'est donc ça que je vais devenir une
quadra américaine ordinaire vivant à
Zurich
comme c'est déprimant
[Musique]
dans ma tête je me vois comme une femme
d'un mètre 80 à la taille fine et au
large épaules
je n'ai jamais aimé mon corps
aujourd'hui je vais pouvoir le
transformer
vous pourriez me faire des jambes plus
longues plus longues bien sûr
regardez-moi ça j'ai l'air d'un top
model oui
c'est amusant on devient vite accro mais
c'est perturbant aussi
féministe et je ne veux pas courir après
ces canons de beauté hors de portée
cette crise Anne là trouverait tout de
suite un mec regardez comme elle est
bien foutue
désolé il y a parfois de la marge entre
ma parole et mes actes
je cherche depuis longtemps à savoir
pourquoi tout le monde est obsédé par
les saints mais je veux aussi comprendre
pourquoi ils sont devenus source de
souffrance pour moi et ce à de nombreux
égards certains voient nos seins comme
des objets sexuels et tout ça mais
noircellement au viol et jusqu'au
féminicides
manifestement mes seins sont tous que
les gens perçoivent de moi comme je ne
peux pas les cacher j'ai décidé de les
montrer de provoquer en jouant avec le
stéréotype de la femme à forte poitrine
[Musique]
bonjour je peux vous interviewer pour
mon documentaire sur les seins
les singes oui
excusez-moi monsieur je peux vous
demander ce que vous pensez de mes seins
ils sont gros en effet ah oui plutôt ils
sont vraiment gros
j'aimerais que ce soit des cerveaux
c'est vrai vous n'avez pas de cerveau ou
quoi bien sûr que si ce sont des vrais
oui ce sont des vrais
ça fait beaucoup
pensez-vous des femmes à gros seins
et puissant comme des canons
l'humanité est divisée en deux pôles un
pôle masculin et un pôle féminin
est attiré par la beauté féminine et les
saints en font partie
les saints les tétons les merveilleux
nichons
ne bougez pas pendant 10 secondes bien
OK et maintenant on va rire en soulevant
les épaules
[Rires]
à un moment de notre vie nous devenons
tout invisible nous ne sommes plus
jeunes et on nous fait croire que nous
sommes inutiles
vous êtes toutes
prêts
mais je le vis mieux entouré de copines
avec de la musique et un peu d'alcool
on s'efforce de tenir bon et de rester
visible
j'ai toujours eu plus de facilité à
attirer l'attention avec mon décolleté
et c'était bien pratique de cacher mon
manque d'assurance derrière mon tour de
poitrine
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
[Musique]
je pense à toi sans arrêt
tu es si belle tu dois avoir tous les
hommes à tes pieds
quand est-ce que tout ça a changé
quand est-ce que moi j'ai changé
j'aimerais redevenir la jeune fille
alors mignonne optimiste et pas encore
obnubilé par sa poitrine
je n'ai jamais voulu être sexy et encore
moins un objet
j'aimais bien qu'on me remarque mais
quand c'était moi qu'il avait décidé
[Musique]
sexy
non ce n'est pas le mot que j'emploie
Christelle était jolie intelligente et
joyeuse innocente une jeune fille comme
beaucoup d'autres elle s'habillait comme
une institutrice elle ne buvait pas ne
fumait pas ne traînez pas avec les
garçons
de taille moyenne normale elle était
bien proportionnée
ça me plaisait bien d'être la gentille
fille la jeune fille innocente tout
s'est bien passé jusqu'à mes 22 ans
là j'ai pris quelques centimètres et mes
seins se sont mis à grossir je suis
passé d'un bon essai à eux et bien plus
encore
à partir de là tout a changé la façon
dont les gens me voyaient et aussi dont
je me voyaient fini la jeune fille
rangée j'étais la femme au gros lolo
j'aimerais t'en retrouver la jeune fille
innocente que j'étais avant de m'a léger
de tout ce poids je rentre aux
États-Unis pour discuter avec ceux qui
m'ont connu quand j'étais juste
Christelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je parle de
[Musique]
bye
SALUT MAMAN
voilà où j'ai grandi une petite ferme du
New Hampshire je détestais cette vie je
m'en prenais aux vaches et je pleurais
dans la grange en chantant les chansons
qui passaient à la télé j'attendais
toujours que quelqu'un vienne me
délivrer
c'est écrit Christelle 83 tu arrives là
exactement
mais attends je ne te touche pas
exactement à cet endroit
je suis plus grande qu'en 1983
dans ma famille c'était à bout de parler
de son corps quand mes règles sont
arrivées je n'avais aucune idée de ce
que c'était et quand mes saints ont
poussé tout ce que je voulais c'était
les cacher
voilà une autre photo de nous tous je
portais un pull large on partait pour
les vacances d'été et je me souviens
qu'au moment des au revoir papa a dit tu
as l'air d'être enceinte devant tout le
monde j'aurais voulu disparaître sous
terre il essayait sûrement d'être drôle
il ne savait pas comment s'y prendre
avec une gamine qui avait peut-être déjà
un petit ami ce genre de chose mais
j'étais mortifié bien sûr tu te rends
compte tu avais 15 ans je portais même
pas de soutien-gorge encore je faisais
maxi un bonnet B tu étais tout à fait
normal oui je devais faire du B
probablement oui quand mes seins se sont
mis à grossir on en a jamais parlé on en
parle pas beaucoup non à cause de la
famille
on ne parlait pas de grand chose à
l'époque de toute façon tu penses quoi
de ma future opération je pense qu'il
est grand temps les médecins que tu as
vu dans le passé prétendaient tout ce
que ça relevait de la chirurgie
esthétique que ce n'était pas nécessaire
je suis curieuse de voir l'impact que ça
aura sur ta personnalité
que va donc devenir la plantureuse
blonde ou brune j'en sais rien
tu seras toujours une belle femme
mais l'intérêt que les hommes portent
actuellement à cette partie de ton corps
va disparaître
c'est vrai tu sors une femme normale et
les hommes continueront à te regarder
dans la rue
c'est tu ne feras pas le même effet
c'est vrai enfin je ne sais pas ce qu'il
pense vraiment ce sera bien mais ce sera
quand même différent c'est ce que je me
dis en tout cas
je pense que ce sera génial parce que je
ne veux plus de cette attention de toute
façon quand on vieillit il ne se
retourne plus comme avant sur moi si
d'accord mais c'est juste que ça arrive
moi souvent je sais
ma mère avait vu une annonce pour le
concours de Miss America ado dans le
journal
ce qui m'a motivé à y participer c'était
le concours des talents
je voulais devenir comédienne et
j'espérais que ce serait la solution
pour échapper à la vie de la ferme
[Musique]
mais c'est le concours de beauté que
j'ai remporté pas le concours des
talents
quelle déception pour moi
[Musique]
grand-mère était là aussi
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est chouette d'avoir ces vidéos c'est
super
[Musique]
personne n'est venu me délivrer de ma
vie à la ferme
à 30 ans j'ai pris mon courage à deux
mains et je suis parti tenter ma chance
en ville comme comédienne je quittais la
région où tout le monde me connaissait
pour New York
et là de nouveau je n'étais qu'une
blonde à gros seins alors j'ai appris à
m'en servir
[Musique]
on ne me proposait que des rôles de
filles sexy ou de prostituées de luxe
[Musique]
je voulais être une comédienne sérieuse
mais avec ce décolleté
le monde ne me voyait pas avec les mêmes
yeux que moi quand je me regardais dans
le miroir
coup de regard en quoi les gens sont
très doués pour ça beaucoup d'hommes
sont très forts pour regarder et
détourner les yeux très vite persuadé
qu'ils n'ont pas fixé vos seins
c'est quand même ce qu'ils ont fait bien
sûr
mais ça ce n'est pas grave
le problème c'est ceux qui matent des
commentaires inappropriés
je m'appelle Christelle et vous pour les
Patricia pewly Patricia vous êtes
magnifique oh merci quand je vous ai vu
passer je me suis dit que vous deviez
être new-yorkaise génial suis new
yorkaise je tourne un documentaire en
fait je suis ici pour je fais un film
sur mes seins alors je vais les
embrasser
c'est ça les vrais New Yorkais pas
d'inhibition enfonce moi je trouve
qu'elle devrait enlever son manteau je
suis de New Yorkaise mais aussi styliste
tu sais je m'en doutais des simples
parce qu'ils sont vraies ça se voit
tu sais à quoi on voit ça non quand on
les embrasse ils rebondissent un peu
j'adore ça
ce sont mes lèvres là
[Musique]
si c'était arrivé quand j'ai débarqué
ici ça m'aurait beaucoup amusé et je
n'en aurai pas fait tout un plat
aujourd'hui je vois mes seins
différemment
[Musique]
à tel point que j'ai même imaginé une
performance artistique pour amener les
gens à réfléchir à ce que mes seins
représentent
j'en ai fait de pures objets
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le poids des saints
veuillez prendre place
l'artiste vous invite à sentir le poids
des seins
maintenant d'accord
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
vous venez de toucher des saints comment
était-ce
un peu oppressant
gênant
moins érotique que je ne le pensais on
dirait un sachet plein d'eau ou de
liquide c'est comme si je touchais un
morceau de viande oui les San ne sont
pas érotiques en soi il faut qu'il soit
relié à une personne du moins pour moi
dissocier de mon corps mes seins ont
l'air de simples blocs de chair inerte
ils ne sont plus sexy c'est même le
contraire
je me suis sentie chose et
je suis un tout
on ne peut pas juste extraire une partie
de moi
sérieusement oui c'est un film sur ta
réduction mammaire oui enfin ça parle de
plein d'autres choses mais oui attends
tu n'es pas sérieuse là si je suis
sérieuse pourquoi pourquoi tu veux
ça te pose un problème mais non mais
ils font partie de toi pourquoi tu veux
changer ça
il y a 15 ans à rôle et moi on a joué
une pièce ensemble à Broadway
[Musique]
il doit bien y avoir une autre solution
que l'opération
tu sais combien de fois on m'a dit ça et
pas que des hommes achète-toi un
meilleur soutien-gorge ou perd un peu de
poids fait plus de gym pour le dos rien
de tout ça ne marche non mais c'est pas
ce que je veux dire je ne suis pas fan
des grosses poitrine ah bien sûr les
tiens ne me dérangeraient pas mais c'est
juste je ne sais pas c'est quand même
une partie de toi je sais oui c'est
comme si tu tuais quelque chose je ne
suis pas pour les implants mammaires non
plus mais une réduction mammaire c'est
encore pire je trouve pourquoi je ne
sais pas je n'ai jamais vraiment pensé
mais je crois que ça me rend triste
pourquoi tu ris effectivement c'est
triste
tu as tout à fait raison je sais que ça
va transformer mon corps mais et si tout
est différent de ce que tu pensais et si
tu le regrettes
j'imagine que tu pourrais t'en faire
rajouter mais il serait artificiel tu ne
peux pas revenir en arrière
et si tu as l'impression d'avoir fait
une erreur bon ce n'est pas mon problème
à moi ça ne me regarde pas oui tu dis
toujours ça ce qui veut dire il fait
trop de protestations ce me semble c'est
de Shakespeare non
tu le sais bien
le regard des hommes sur mes seins
m'importe toujours je n'en suis pas fier
finalement je les considère et les
utilise moi-même comme des objets
[Musique]
pourtant mon rapport au sein a changé
dès que j'ai eu un enfant
je suis contente de te voir moi aussi
j'arrive pas à croire que tu viens
d'avoir un bébé moi non plus
chouette de te voir coucou
on dirait qu'il sait exactement ce qu'il
y a là je sais ce qu'il y a la maman oui
aller Paris
et c'est tout nouveau
apparemment Freud avait l'habitude de
dire à ses patients
je suis le saint
je me suis dit il faut absolument que je
raconte ça à Christelle il disait je
suis le saint comme si la portait
absolument tout à ses patients comme le
sein maternelles
comme s'il était à la fois le père et la
mère j'ai réfléchi en venant ici
aujourd'hui et je me disais je suis le
saint je suis le saint je suis le saint
tu as la meilleure des mamans oh oui
[Musique]
les seins sont faits pour allaiter les
bébés mais avant ça il servent à attirer
notre sexe pour pouvoir avoir un bébé
[Musique]
mes seins en nourri ma fille ils ont
rempli leur mission je n'aurais pas
d'autres enfants alors il est temps
qu'il se fasse un peu plus discret
[Musique]
en voilà encore une
vache tu plaisantes pourquoi tu crois
que je t'ai fait venir et comme dit ma
mère c'est toujours bon d'avoir un homme
à la maison mais c'est sexiste et ça
fait pas avancer mon combat féministe
mais c'est quand même bien d'avoir un
homme sous la main pour porter des trucs
lourds surtout quand on a mal au dos
mais toi aussi tu as mal au dos donc on
est mal barré
ok c'est parti
laissez-moi passer
et surtout n'approchez pas trop près de
ma voiture
j'adore conduire je me serais bien vu
taxi à New York je ferai ça très bien je
pense
je pourrais en faire mon métier à
condition que personne ne me fasse de
mal ne m'agresse ne me drague bêtement
ou ne me tue
me voilà en route pour Hollywood la
ville où les clichés se créent et se
perpétuent
[Musique]
jeune comédienne je n'ai pas osé
m'installer à Los Angeles
on sait que je ne percerai jamais à la
barre que je n'étais pas assez belle pas
assez mince pas assez bronzés pas assez
blonde pas assez cool
bienvenue à Hollywood vous êtes arrivés
merci c'est très gentil à vous
[Musique]
jamais assez étroit à la fois aux
auditions comme sur les plateaux je
m'efforçais sans cesse de faire oublier
mon buste mais il me volait toujours la
vedette
la voilà
ma copine Jane
une fois lors d'un casting le metteur en
scène est sorti et j'ai pu voir ses
notes à côté de mon nom il avait juste
écrit ça
mon corps était mon piège mais il aurait
pu être une chance aussi je me demande
combien de ces femmes ont dû se plier au
désir des hommes qui leur promettaient
de faire d'elle des stars
je n'ai jamais suivi un producteur
puissant dans une chambre d'hôtel pour
faire décoller ma carrière
personne ne devrait avoir à le faire
[Musique]
OK
ah ok la réservation est à quel nom
à très bientôt chez nous
excusez-moi de ma franchise mais en
entrant dans le restaurant j'ai remarqué
votre beau sourire votre visage et puis
j'ai vu votre poitrine je tourne
justement un film sur les seins et
normalement c'est toujours moi la mieux
pourvu de toutes mais là c'est vous et
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de dire oh mon
dieu
merci et si je peux me permettre moi je
fais du 95 HH quelle taille vous
faites-vous du 95 g ou h mais j'ai le
plus souvent parfois h ces variables
mais c'est à peu près ça en général
j'ai commencé par des bonnets eux
c'était top et puis Eve ça allait encore
mais après je suis passé au bonnet G
puis h puis HH
c'est déjà lourd mais
c'est carrément l'horreur
[Rires]
doublement l'horreur bon je gère en fait
ça fait tellement longtemps que je vis
avec mais ma mère n'arrête pas de me
dire qu'il faut que je fasse quelque
chose et ma grand-mère trouve que si je
me dépêche pas de le faire ce sera trop
tard après mais ce sont mes amis oui
c'est comme des potes quel est le
meilleur moment de la journée pour vous
quand j'enlève mon soutien-gorge pareil
à la maison je tiens pas plus de 5
minutes avec
les femmes à petite poitrine n'ont
jamais de troisième sein
là c'est comme d'avoir un troisième ça
en milieu tu es toujours en train de
chez moi je m'habille que quand je dois
sortir c'est la toute dernière chose que
je fais d'enfiler mon soutien-gorge et
mes vêtements je me coiffe je me
maquille je me douche je mange tout ça
en peignoir
quand j'ai fini tout le reste j'enfile
cette instrument de torture qui les
maintient si bien
et puis j'ouvre la porte je me redresse
et je me jette dans la fosse aux lions
pareil pour les câlins les tripotages et
les photos
vous avez l'impression d'être un objet
que les gens ne vous prennent pas au
sérieux à cause de vos seins tout à fait
comme ça tout le temps dans mes
différents boulots en société
on me traite toujours comme une moins
que rien qui ne penserait qu'à planter
ses faux seins sous le nez de tous les
hommes mais je ne suis absolument pas
comme ça je suis plutôt gentil et amical
je ne les ai pas achetés ils sont
d'origine alors je me redresse et je
l'élève bien haut comme les coins de mes
lèvres quand je souris et je fais ce que
je peux
j'ai vécu des expériences traumatisantes
quand j'étais plus jeune
en CM1 j'avais déjà des bons essais et
ça m'a valu pas mal de remarques les
concierges de l'école avaient des propos
très déplacés
vers 20 ans j'avais un job à mi-temps
dans un entrepôt
et l'un des directeurs est venu me dire
que je déconcentrais mes collègues
j'ai répondu comment ça dès que j'arrive
je travaille dur et je suis toujours en
jean et t-shirt je ne fais que
travailler jour après jour ils ne font
pas bien leur travail ne venez pas me
dire que je les distrais dites-leur
plutôt d’arrêter de flirter avec moi et
de se concentrer sur leur boulot
j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes au travail
on me disait toujours que c'était ma
faute ou que je perturbais les autres
comme si j'étais dangereuse pour la
communauté juste une bimbo qui vient
mettre la pagaille
[Musique]
je suis toujours en colère quand je
pense au nombre de fois où l'on m'a
tripoté sifflée harceler et pire encore
les seins sont tellement présents dans
l'espace public que les gens font comme
si leur partenaire on les transfigurent
on en fait des objets et pour je ne sais
quelle raison quand une femme en a
beaucoup on part du principe qu'elle
veut les montrer au monde entier qu'elle
attendait commentaire et qu'elle est
forcément stupide ça met souvent arrivé
même à Zurich qui n'est pas vraiment un
endroit où les hommes vous sifflent mais
même là-bas j'ai entendu des hommes
lâchés ce genre de commentaires ces
dernières années un type qui marchait à
côté de moi s'est arrêté et il s'est mis
à me fixer je lui ai dit qu'est-ce qu'il
y a il a répondu ils sont
extraordinaires c'est des vrais et une
fois de plus je me suis sentie blessée
harceler
c'est du harcèlement sexuel verbal ça
peut paraître extrême mais c'est
vraiment ce que je ressens
et ce n'est qu'un exemple j'ai fait des
expériences encore pire encore plus
désagréables comme n'importe quelle
femme
c'est comme si nous devions avoir honte
de notre corps et le cacher et quand
nous le montrons les autres le
considèrent comme leur propriété
je suis claustro OK
voilà c'est la
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous avec mon ami Jenny et
sa mère iris Jenny et moi on s'est
connus avant que ma poitrine n'explose
et quand ça a commencé et que j'essayais
désespérément de la cacher c'est elle
qui m'a dit que c'était normal d'avoir
des seins
tu sais après la naissance de Jenny je
suis passée des bonnets des au bon essai
ça m'a complètement déconcerté j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir perdu quelque chose
d'important tout d'un coup j'avais
l'impression de ne plus avoir autant de
valeur
parce que tes seins étaient plus petits
je me souviens que j'en parle et souvent
à David mais ça en rapetissait
mais ça faisait partie de mon identité
avant j'avais des bonnets des
ans je voyais déjà que j'attirais
l'attention d'hommes beaucoup plus âgé
que moi
et si j'attirais leur attention c'était
à cause de mes bonnets c'est
je me rappelle parfaitement bien de
cette époque là j'avais déjà des seins
de femmes
et j'attirai les regards ça ne faisait
aucun doute mais je ne voulais pas de
cette attention là
on avait toutes des seins dans la
famille ma mère ses soeurs moi
en quatrième j'avais des bonnets c'est
on avait tout dessin
et de toute évidence
il suscitait du désir
papa te photographier les seins nus
quand même c'est vrai
les hommes adorent photographier les
femmes nues c'est comme ça
ils le font naturellement et c'est de
l'art de la oui c'est clair tu vois bien
ce que je veux dire
ce qui me dérange vraiment
j'espère que c'est quand les femmes
doivent cacher leur corps sous une burqa
c'est ça qui me dérange
ça veut dire qu'on ne les accepte pas
dans toute leur humanité parce qu'elles
sont des femmes
et qu'elle pourrait faire tourner la
tête d'un homme par leur propre faute
on nous voit comme des objets sexuels
pas comme des êtres humains des choses
que l'on peut regarder et posséder
j'en ai tellement marre de m'accrocher
désespérément à ma jeunesse et d'être
déprimé quand je me regarde dans le
miroir
[Musique]
pourquoi ne devrais-je pas me sentir
sexy forte et sûre de moi à mon âge quel
que soit la taille de mes seins
[Musique]
Sam était mon petit ami quand j'avais 18
ans c'est-à-dire avant les saints
j'avais tendresse
ça fait si longtemps oui
je fais un film
sur mes seins ok je vais me faire opérer
[Musique]
tu en as parlé à ta fille oui elle le
sait qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit elle m'a
demandé de combien je lui ai dit que
j'allais passer d'extra large à médium
pourquoi tu fais ça j'ai mal au dos au
cervicales des migraines sans arrêt ah
oui
ce sera sympa aussi de porter d'autres
vêtements sans qu'on me regarde comme un
phénomène de foire je n'ai pas peur de
l'opération je m'inquiète juste de
savoir comment je me sentirais après au
niveau identité émotion on a une
relation d'amour haine mais ça et moi
c'est une bénédiction et une malédiction
à la fois et une part très importante de
mon identité car j'en ai fait des objets
comme tout le monde je suis la fille aux
gros seins
et je crains de devenir invisible sans
eux et dis-moi si je n'avais pas ce
décolleté tu me remarquerait dans la rue
bonne question et bien
je pense que oui parce que tu es dans ma
tranche d'âge j'ai 50 ans toi la
quarantaine et tu es très sexy merci
bien sûr que je te remarquerai et je te
draguerai certainement
tu as de gros seins c'est clair et je
les remarque en tant qu'homme
mais il se trouve que je te connais et
je te trouve séduisante quelle que soit
la taille de tes seins
ils sont beaux c'est sûr et n'importe
quel homme aimerait avoir à son bras
mais c'est juste un avantage en plus
un truc avec lequel je pourrais frimer
devant mes potes elle a des dessins
énormes c'est génial mais c'est plus
pour filmer les hommes sont comme ça
parfois c'est vrai
se marier elle a dit pourquoi tu poses
pas sa famille je pense que c'est ce qui
va arriver tu crois qu'on va se marier
un jour vraiment quand
et bien
dans 5 ou 6 ans peut-être tu reviens à
elle
oui vraiment je serais prêt à parier
qu'il y a toujours pas mal d'attirance
entre nous enfin je dis ça tu dis ça oui
je l'ai toujours senti
je pense que c'est vrai
dans 5 6 ans alors
je le note dans mon agenda
google
est-ce qu'on veut vraiment se marier
je sais pas on veut vraiment se marier
je me défile déjà tu défiles encore une
fois décidément
bon alors on dit quoi
2020 avril on est en quelle année la 17
que dirais-tu de 2025 c'est trop tard
très bien c'est dans 8 ans
[Rires]
tu es adorable si tu vas me manquer
[Musique]
je viens d'apprendre que tu envisages
une réduction mammaire tu as une super
poitrine ne la fait pas raboter je t'en
prie tu vas te faire réduire les seins
c'est un crime contre l'humanité on n'a
pas le droit de toucher à des globes
pareil
c'est ta carte de visite ma belle tu
n'as pas de cancer de quoi tu te plains
ils vont beaucoup me manquer j'adore tes
seins tu me les donnes garde-les tu
sauras comme toutes les autres sinon
c'est ma décision je le fais pour moi
j'ai travaillé dur pour en arriver là et
il est temps je serai peut-être moins
visible mais plus forte
[Musique]
avant de rentrer à Zurich pour faire la
connaissance de la nouvelle tristesse au
sein moins généreux
j'ai une dernière visite à faire
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'ai vu ma sœur
Kira elle était encore mon petit frère
[Musique]
je lui ai demandé si ça l'avait
transformé de vivre pleinement en tant
que femme elle m'a répondu je ne suis ni
une fille ni un garçon je suis juste moi
[Musique]
quand on sera à deux dessus tu poses ton
pied ici je trouve formidable que Kira
n'est jamais cessé de faire ce qu'elle
aimait sous prétexte que cela ne se
faisait pas pour une fille
aujourd'hui encore elle adore la vitesse
et le danger et elle s'est tout réparée
c'est très amusant et c'est aussi stable
et facile que ça en a l'air
et puis si tu tombes c'est dans la neige
bon je m'accroche ici alors et je
m'appuie bien contre toi il y a rien
d'autre que je doivent savoir on va
faire juste une petite boucle ne me tue
pas chérie mais tout va bien se passer
maman serait pas contente que je meurs
oui le mien aussi
[Musique]
tu voulais avoir les cheveux longs quand
tu étais petit toujours mais j'avais pas
le droit on me les coupait
c'était mignon ta petite brosse oh non
j'avais horreur de ça je faisais tout ce
que je pouvais mais tu t'en sors jamais
quand on me dit sans arrêt tu te prends
pour un hippie ou quoi j'essayais juste
d'être moi-même mais on se moquait tout
le temps de moi parce que les gens
n'acceptaient pas que je laisse pousser
mes cheveux
les petites filles n'ont pas de problème
avec ça elles peuvent aussi les avoir
court elles peuvent faire ce qu'elles
veulent pour s'exprimer les petits
garçons eux doivent correspondre à des
stéréotypes
c'est vrai tu as raison
mais une fois plus âgé les filles
doivent s'adapter au stéréotypes féminin
et les garçons pensent tous qu'ils
doivent être de vrais hommes et refouler
tout ce qu'il y a de féminin en eux
c'est un sacré bazar au niveau
psychologique ce petit jeu qui est
comment on doit être comment il faut se
représenter ça m'étonne même que
certains y arrivent
il en faut du courage pour se libérer
des attentes des autres et être soi Kira
est bien plus courageuse que moi mais je
progresse
[Musique]
retour en Suisse
je n'ai aucune idée de la taille des
vêtements que je porterai après demain
[Musique]
la perspective de l'opération me rend un
peu nerveuse
mes seins ont obsédé des années durant
je m'en suis servie pour attirer
l'attention pour des projets artistiques
et pour remettre en question les
représentations habituelles des femmes
et des corps
je vais prendre votre tension ok de
l'autre côté merci
pourquoi à gauche c'est plus près du
coeur ah oui bien sûr
on ne m'a pas appris ça à l'école
posez votre bras et essayez de vous
détendre
nous y voilà il est temps de se dire au
revoir il est temps de se dire au revoir
oui tout va bien se passer ça ira
alors
ah dans quelques
heures tu seras toujours la même je
serai toujours la même et je dirais
toujours ce que je pense avec ce rire de
dingue avec ce rire de dingue
je quitte le costume de la femme aux
gros seins
c'était celui d'un rôle que je ne joue
plus
il est temps d'accueillir un mois plus
authentique
mes saints ne sont pas moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]